i like uncle biden i'd say nine i give
him a six i i literally have no idea
what he's doing
how is president biden do it
it's more like one to ten on how much i
care probably
like a five i would say five minus ten
seven oh
minus zero zero
i mean i'd say he's doing what like
seven i guess i don't know i don't like
how he calls kamala harris president
harris oh i think he's doing a great job
because he's trying really hard to get
us out of the mess that our last
president created you like inflation
okay you like illegal criminals coming
across the border
if you like where he killed the gasoline
i think he's doing a much better job
than the former former president who
shall not be named he shall not be named
i think he's got his heart in the right
place but his policies uh don't have
that much effect well some of the things
that he
implemented just aren't going over well
with the with the people i think that we
have better candidates that were suited
for the office and i just feel like
we need a change we have two parties
here republican party and the communist
party